but first our breaking news this morning
the british iranian national nazanin
zagari radcliffe has had her british
passport returned according to her mp
tulip sadiq she said that she
understands that there is a british
negotiating team in tehran where she is
being detained while shinki maruriki is
in the newsroom for us this morning uh
this is positive news isn't it jingy uh
could she potentially be coming home
that's right jane she could potentially
be coming home or at least it feels like
a big breakthrough in the long battle to
bring nazanin zagari ratcliffe back to
the uk she was of course imprisoned in
2016 while visiting iran with her young
daughter gabriela and since then one of
the campaigners pushing for her release
was her local mp tulip sadiq who's quite
close to the case and earlier on this
morning she confirmed that her passport
had been returned in this tweet here she
said i'm very pleased to say that nazdin
zagara ratcliff has been given her
british passport back she's still at her
family home in tehran i also understand
that there is a british negotiating team
in tehran right now i will keep posting
updates as i get them she's spent the
last year or so in parole at her parents
home in tehran but there was always the
looming fear that she could be returned
to prison at any point which is why
negotiators being in the country feels
like such a huge moment there are people
on the ground talking to the authorities
in iran about her release which seems to
be based on or contingent on this 400
million pound debt relating to a
cancelled order for tanks dating back to
the 1970s we don't know if the
discussions are around those but that
has been frequently discussed when
discussing when talking about this story
it's of course been a protracted saga in
which her husband richard ratcliffe has
campaigned for justice he had a hunger
strike outside of the foreign office
last year lasting 21 days and it's no
deal which is taking a toll on all of
their family but it looks like this
could be a big moment it looks like this
could potentially be a breakthrough in
the efforts to bring her back to the uk